am sonntag wurde gefeiert lautstark weil
der cdu eher verhalten bei den
bündnisgrünen beide hatten jedenfalls
gute gründe für spd und fdp blieb nur
die option sich ein mieses wahlergebnis
schön zu laufen und das hat folgen für
den fortgang der sogenannten
fortschritts koalition in berlin jubeln
schock die ampel nach der nrw-wahl jetzt
in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst hier im studio anja maier
hauptstadtjournalisten von die
korrespondentinnen und sie sind
korrespondentin unter anderem für den
weser-kurier und die zeit für die sie
aus der hauptstadt berichten frank meyer
ist kolumnist der zeitschrift cicero
phonetische sind sie ihm gleich glauben
dürfen aber hier gerne unterschiedliche
meinungen äußern zugeschaltet
professorin andrea römmele
politikwissenschaftlerin von der hertie
school und reinhard schlinkert ist bei
uns meinungsforscher von infratest dimap
frau meier ist denn die ampel euphorie
schon dahin oder ist das
nrw-ergebnis eher landespolitisch zu
deuten naja die das ergebnis ist
natürlich erstmal ein echter dämpfer für
die ampel aber nur für teile der ampel
also für spd und fdp die grünen können
ja ich ganz froh sein und ich denke mal
es wird jetzt schwieriger in den
nächsten monaten auf jeden fall das wird
die die einzelnen fraktionen parteien
müssen sich neu orientieren einen daran
was die wählerinnen und wähler ihnen
gesagt haben dann bei den beiden
zurückliegenden landtagswahlen und das
wird jetzt spannend in der nächsten zeit
nach der bundestagswahl hat ja die
spd-spitze das sozialdemokratische
jahrzehnt ausgerufen ein kollege ein
kollege hat jetzt geschrieben manchmal
dauert ein jahrzehnt doch nur zu etwa
sechs monate ist da irgendetwas in der
ja in der perspektive in der projektion
für die spd schief gelaufen was
sicherlich ist es so dass die ampel
koalition dass bundeskanzler chance
jetzt so was wie einen neustart und auch
eine neujustierung
hinlegen muss wir hatten jetzt rein
landtagswahlen bei der ersten
landtagswahl im saarland hat die spd
noch groß gepunktet stellt dort eine
alleinregierung mit der
ministerpräsidentin rehlinger aber in
der tat sowohl in schleswig holstein als
auch jetzt in nordrhein westfalen hat
die cdu den weg nach hause getragen und
gerade in nordrhein westfalen wird wir
bezeichnen ja nordrhein-westfalen immer
auch als sowas wie eine kleine
bundestagswahl
das ergebnis ist absolut ernst zu nehmen
um zurückzukommen auf ihre frage gerade
vorher es ist landtagswahl aber wie
gesagt auch kleine bundestagswahl
und da muss die ampel jetzt wirklich
überlegen da muss die spd jetzt wirklich
überlegen wie sie sich neu ausrichtet
wenn man ja an der mauer ist ja gerade
schon gesagt nicht alle ampel farben
sind
in irgendeiner weise
beschädigt worden die bündnisgrünen
stehen ja gut da was machen die
bündnisgrünen eigentlich richtig was spd
und fdp falsch machen sie machen haben
sich richtig was sie zu tun haben im
wirtschaftsministerium und umwelt und im
außenministerium das sind natürlich
jetzt wie man so sagt die angesagten
ministerien da hatten sie auch glück da
als sie die besetzten hat wahrscheinlich
christian lindner noch gedacht das
finanzministerium ein mächtiges
ministerium das hat die größere
ausstrahlung aber die welt hat sich
verändert die hat sich total verändert
und wenn man die leistung oder die
performance von von bundeskanzler scholz
anguckt dann muss man sehen als er die
ampel machte war das schon ein
gesamtkunstwerk das hat es vorher nie
gegeben
das war schon schwierig und jetzt
verändert sich noch die ganze welt also
gewicht der ministerien werden anders
also da bin ich etwas nachsichtig dass
der welle da nicht nachsichtig ist ist
auch in ordnung aber ich würde sagen und
es braucht zeit damit sich das
einpendeln und die zeit wird der ja wohl
auch noch haben er schlinger der begriff
kleine bundestagswahl manchmal so ein
bisschen abgegriffen aber er ist ja
schon gefallen möglicherweise ist es
tatsächlich eine was hat denn aus sicht
des meinungsforschers demoskopen die
menschen dazu gebracht den zu wählen und
vor allen dingen was hat das ganze
eigentlich mit berlin zu tun
als erstes muss man sagen das sind ja
viel weniger menschen zur wahl gegangen
als vor fünf jahren und insgesamt
hat auch die cdu die wahl gewonnen hat
weniger wähler als sie das vor fünf
jahren hatte in absoluten zahlen am
interessantesten finden wir bisher immer
wieder über berlin gesprochen und
bundestagswahl ich fand am
interessantesten gegenkandidaten faktor
das heißt wie sehr haben denn die
eigenen kandidaten gezogen das war bei
der cdu mit wies am stärksten 33 prozent
ist auch keine superzahl dann kam schon
der partie bei der fdp waren es war
gerade zehn prozent und bei den grünen
nur neun prozent kandidat weil er fast
80 prozent sagten das ist das programm
von der fdp fw ein wenig von den grünen
was uns gefällt oder ist schon
bemerkenswert und auch bemerkenswert war
wir haben darüber gefragt ob die hilfe
von scholz und den grünen
spitzenpolitikern harbecke und der woche
und auch lindner eine hilfe im wahlkampf
waren und das war schon interessant an
der spitze natürlich es im moment sehr
populären minister habe kommt berbalk
also große hilfe für die für die grünen
und dann kam schon der lindner von dem
also auch immerhin 50 prozent sagte
barner große hilfe für die für die wahl
für die eigene partei in nordrhein
westfalen obwohl sie es nicht geholfen
hat und dann bei der spd war sehr stolz
wo es auch nur die hälfte der wähler
gesagt haben er war eine unterstützung
im wahlkampf
das finde ich ja am interessantesten und
die gründe warum die leute die einzelnen
parteien gewählt haben ganz oben stand
die preissteigerung und
energiefragen und das zutraue und das
bag die energieversorgung auch in
zukunft aufrechterhalten kann für
deutschland war bei zwei drittel der
wähler
weiter zwei drittel der wählerzustimmung
und das ist natürlich muss man sich auch
klar sagen ein großer hype für die
grünen die jetzt gerade auch wir gerade
schon gesagt worden zwei ministerien
besetzt zu haben wo die menschen die
natürlich sagen ich habe sorge dass der
krieg sich ausweitet sagen immerhin
republik fast zwei drittel der menschen
dass die beiden dafür stehen die ängste
der menschen hier was energieversorgung
und natürlich auch krieg man geht zu
minimieren
gut das war jetzt die wahlanalyse wir
wollen vielleicht noch mal ein schritt
zurück gehen und schauen was hat denn
letztendlich zu diesem wahlergebnis
geführt wenn es denn bundespolitische
einflüsse auch gab wenn wir auf den
letzten herbst zurücksehen auf die
koalitionsverhandlung da hatte man ja
das gefühl da sind drei parteien dabei
das rad neu zu erfinden so nach dem
motto früher war alles schlecht war dass
allzu große tollkühnheit hat man da
vielleicht geflissentlich die falken
übersehen die gerade auf eine ampel
warten könnten
jemand ein bisschen zu optimistisch war
und dachte das kriegen wir schon weil
wir den hohen preis einfordern waren es
vielleicht die fdp die gedacht hat das
funktioniert schon wir sind quasi jetzt
mal ob's klappt sich gesagt so harte
hunde die die wissen schon wir haben wir
haben schon mal jamaika platzen lassen
wir stellen hier unsere bedingungen und
das ist jetzt die haben quasi sohn runde
womit der realität also das ist ja der
hammer schon gesagt dass das
finanzministerium sich zu holen
regelrecht zu holen zu erzwingen das
wollten ja echt grün
war wahrscheinlich ein guter beruf aber
jetzt ist herr linder in der position
ständig die schulden machen zu müssen
das ist konnte er nicht wissen aber das
ist zum beispiel so ein punkt wo jetzt
die leute natürlich genau hinschauen
also die die fdp ist nicht in der macher
position und das sind die grünen und bei
der bei der spd muss man sagen die haben
natürlich gedacht wir bestellen einfach
den ruhigen herrn scholz in der regel
dass und behält die nerven aber dieses
nerven behalten hat wahrscheinlich auch
nicht an dieser postmärkte lehrer noch
irgendwie quasi magisch gewirkt aber das
hat sich jetzt verbraucht auch weil die
zeiten sich verändert haben weil die
realpolitik schneller härter und teurer
geworden ist
naja ich darf ja ab da wird sie haben
die märkte jahre genannt wurde es ist
medienpolitisch ganz wichtig ich habe
den eindruck dass unsere kollegen wir
uns schadens halten nachdem wir 16 jahre
unglaublich brav zurückhaltend zum teil
in der rolle von beck vorlegen waren der
kanzlerin gegenüber und scholz bekommt
wahnsinnig viel ab was die kompensation
ist also jedes wort wasser sagt eine
zeitlang war hat es so gesagt hat das so
gesagt er kommt es nicht richtig machen
ich bedauere ihn deswegen nicht aber
dieses phänomen das wir jetzt mal
losgehen dürfen was wir 16 jahren nicht
taten das ist einfach ein kompensations
phänomen mit dem diese regierung
konfrontiert ist sie wollten das noch
ergänzt also eine ganz kurze schlinkert
eine frau stehen hat eine frau wenn wir
einen moment bitte
ja ich würde er war zwei sachen sagen
erstens hat scholz natürlich nicht die
beste karte gezogen er wusste ja nicht
dass er krieges kanzler wird 20 seine
roller natürlich schon schwierig weil
die hälfte der bevölkerung sagt wir
haben angst davor oder noch mehr dass
der krieg sich ausweiten sollte und es
gibt auch eine große anzahl von menschen
in deutschland die sagen wir so ein
bisschen zurückhaltender sein also er
hat es nicht leicht das der punkt eins
zu der fdp die fdp hat natürlich jetzt
ein riesen strukturelles problem
die wähler die sie gewählt haben für die
zur bundestagswahl
die sind inzwischen ein bisschen
abgerückt davon was gerade dass gerade
die jungen leute noch die fdp in
nordrhein westfalen gewählt haben aber
bei den älteren ab 60 jahren ist die fdp
unter ferner liefen
das liegt natürlich auch daran dass hier
in der 3 das in nordrhein westfalen die
fdp letztes mal gewählt worden ist um
rot-grün abzuwählen und das ist eine
andere fdp als diejenige die jetzt in
einer ampel koalition in berlin gegangen
also die abstrafung verdoppelt dann noch
mit dem unpopulären kandidaten die fdp
wird es also außerordentlich schwer
haben ihre positionen in zukunft auch in
wählerstimmen umzusetzen wir gehen auf
die nrw-wahl nochmal ein fr melle die
frage war ja jetzt was ist am anfang
falsch gelaufen vielleicht noch ergänzt
um meine frage war da auch die hoffnung
da dass sich eine deklassierte union
cdu/csu nicht so schnell erholen werden
nach dieser bundestagswahl
nein ich glaube die hoffnung war nicht
da und die war ehrlich gesagt auch nicht
notwendig weil die ampel ja zu recht mit
viel enthusiasmus und auch energie und
engagement im september letzten jahres
gestartet ist und sie hat sich natürlich
wahnsinnig viel vorgenommen muss sich
auch wahnsinnig viel vornehmen weil eben
dieser große transformation druck auch
da steht und hat sich das narrativ in
den konditionen oder für den
koalitionsvertrag gegeben mehr
fortschritt wagen mit dem stichwort
narrativ bin ich schon bei einem ganz
zentralen punkt was die koalition und
was vor allem auch den bundeskanzler
angelangt man muss gerade jetzt in
kriegszeiten das galt für die
transformation schon aber jetzt müssen
wir ja transformationen in einem völlig
neuen koordinatensystem denken es gilt
dass man bürgerinnen und bürger
mitnehmen muss man muss sie kommunikativ
auch mitnehmen das machen robert habeck
und annalena baerbock
exzellent und dagegen schaut natürlich
der bundeskanzler etwas blass aus weil
es nicht sein naturell ist wann ist
natürlich auch nicht ganz sein job ist
also ein bundeskanzler muss nicht jedes
tagesgeschäft kommentieren aber und ich
glaube das war ein stück weit auch die
quittung in nordrhein-westfalen was an
bundespolitischen themen hier
eingespielt hat ist dass der
bundeskanzler schwickert hat es gerade
angesprochen er hatte es nicht einfach
weil er den druck in der koalition spürt
was die ukraine anbelangt mehr waffen zu
liefern aber ein großer teil der
bevölkerung ist demgegenüber auch
skeptisch und darauf muss er eingehen
aber hier bedarf es mehr kommunikation
als er bisher gezeigt hat er ist am 8
meyer vor die kameras getreten was ich
einen einen guten schritt einen für
einen sinnvollen schritt hielt aber ich
denke dass er hier noch deutlich
nachlegen muss wie könnte man den
diensten zur frau meier die zensuren für
diese drei parteien würden die aussehen
bis zum beginn des ukraine kriegs denn
das war ja wirklich eine zäsur ich meine
jetzt die zensuren für die drei paar
tagen könnte man sagen eine
selbstgefällige spd inklusive kanzler
eine halb starke fdp und eine mit sich
hadern der bündnisgrüne partei das haben
sich schön formuliert ich kann es kaum
besser ergänzen aber tatsächlich war es
so dass wenn wir uns nochmal zurück
erinnern an die zeit kurz nach der wahl
war es ja so dass fdp und grüne quasi
wie so ein power couple gebildet haben
indem sie diese sie kennen diese dieses
11 die situation so zu sagen wir halten
zusammen urlaub kommen rüber mal gucken
was was du begeben uns ausrichten kannst
das ist lange verraucht inzwischen
glaube ich also man hört ja hier in
berlin auch öfter mal das große stöhnend
vor allem über die fdp aus den anderen
beiden parteien aber auch umgekehrt
diese dieses schöne
anfangszeit die sachen ihm und er ist
einfach rum jetzt und es hat aber eben
wie gesagt wir haben wirklich handfeste
gründe frau robyn gesagt gerade sie hat
keinen hunden gesehen habe ich das
richtig glaube ich glaube keine 100 tage
frist sogar richtig los das hat
natürlich auch aktuelle gründe jetzt
soll ich bei interessant dann bei der
frage wie ihr krisen
gestellt und die krisenfest ist diese
koalition da gab es ja krisen die
voraussehbaren pandemie krone auch die
diskussionen die in pflicht und eine die
keiner vorausgesehen hatte mehr als eine
krise so eine massive bedrohung europas
durch den ukraine krieg trotzdem
wirklich die ampel da immer bei all
diesen krisen momenten die ja auch immer
noch anhalten wirkte eigentlich schlecht
aufgestellt und schnell überfordert
schnell überfordert und haben nicht auf
dem punkt also es gibt zwar sozusagen
große gesellschaftspolitische projekte
aber wenn wir jetzt zum beispiel die die
impfpflicht sehen das hat sie ja nicht
durchgesetzt letztlich also das ist
jetzt unter großem getöse
um eine alte frau professorin und oder
großem aufeinander ja mit dem finger
zeigen irgendwie gescheitert auch
natürlich an der opposition die jetzt
stärker und stärker wird auch durch die
letzte wahl aber im moment ich vermisse
das ja also da ich glaube dass viele
wählerinnen und wähler gerade aus diesem
sommer mal
reformlager wie gesagt sich da mehr
versprochen haben und das ist bis jetzt
nicht eingetreten eine
ganz kleine ich teile das alles was frau
meyer gesagt hat nur an einer stelle
würde ich glaube ich ein bisschen anders
investieren würde nicht sagen dass die
koalition bei der impfpflicht nicht auf
den punkt kam sondern dass es
letztendlich führung hat vermissen
lassen was zumindest aus meiner sicht
ein bisschen nach andere eine andere
gemengelage ist ich wollte bevor ihn die
frage stelle ob olaf scholz ungerecht
behandelten deutlichkeit sie haben ja
für ihn jetzt gerade eine bresche
geschlagen damit allerdings mit einem
argument dass
glaube ich nicht alle teilen wenn ich
das richtig verstanden habe 16 jahre
hofberichterstattung der presse bei
angela merkel und jetzt ist die presse
plötzlich befreit und fällt über den ex
besten bundeskanzler her ist das nicht
ein bisschen zu starker tobak zu sagen
dass in 16 jahren jetzt artikel 5 presse
und meinungsfreiheit in deutschland
nicht gut weil arminia da aber ich bitte
sie das sind viele kollegen die das auch
sagen es war ein oben war ich also
erzähle wenn wir von den problemen reden
die deutschland jetzt habt aber wir
gehen zurück sind sie in den 16 jahren
angerichtet wurden auch die ganze
geschichte mit putin und 9 und läuft sie
im 2 also und und es ist es herrscht ein
schweigen immer noch zu den
verantwortlichen personen die ware
regierungschefin und darum komme ich
drauf da es ist auch normal dass der
chance er will ja kann sein ich bedauere
ihn doch gar nicht ist doch ganz normal
dass er das alles abbekommt ich
widerspreche in der sache ja gar nicht
sondern in dieser feststellung die
medien hätten das alles sozusagen
sehenden auges mitgemacht also ich würde
ich dagegen auch verwarnt wird olaf
scholz ich würde sich sofort ausnehmend
gut danke
herr meier wird olaf scholz jetzt nicht
in bezug auf die 16 jahre zuvor sondern
auf das was er gerade macht
ungerecht beurteilt
man wirft ihm ihr zaudern zu
entschlossenes handeln vor ist das
gerecht ist dass ich würde der frauen zu
bestimmen was jetzt nötig ist es sie
haben gesagt sind wirklich ernste zeiten
sind sie haben das wort bedrohung
gebraucht also ist wir sind bedroht das
ist ganz klar wir sind irgendwie bedroht
in dieser zeit muss er sein männer führt
seine führung erklären muss irrt zählen
sie haben dass der erzählung ich hasse
das sonst dieses narrativ und ja überall
wo er setzt ja schon das grundgesetz
also aber er müsste jetzt erzählen was
er tut und dass es nicht tut oder dass
es ungelenk tut liegt an ihm das handeln
von ihm dass sie haben sie auch gesagt
vorsichtig sein weil es gibt die
mehrheit es gibt die tendenzen er ist
hier umsichtig ist umsichtig das
umsichtige gehört auch zu ihm das kann
man ihm nicht vorwerfen
natürlich kann man andere meinung haben
aber er musste die erzählung bringen er
muss dazu präsent sein und jetzt kommt's
mich auf den punkt wie es denn die spd
präsent wer war denn vor den wahlen
präsent diese knabe kevin kühnert mit
seiner geschichte dass er in berlin
keine wohnung findet weil in den
zeitungen auf machen es ist doch
unfassbar was sollen die leute von vom
der spd halten von diesem
generalsekretärs ein knabe ein kabel
dennoch nie was geleistet hat und wer
ist denn die die basis der und was ist
schlechtes wort wer ist denn die
wirtschaft das sind einfache leute die
leisten die gehen morgens um 7 raus und
die kinder in die schule zu bringen das
ist das publikum der spd und nicht
irgendwelche
seiner karriere schlingert wenn wir
waren anschließend die hat ja die hat
die demoskopie eigentlich das jetzt
verfolgen können seit dem spätherbst
letzten jahres gerade was scholz angeht
in der wahrnehmung der bevölkerung auch
in seiner bewertung denn die ist im
moment ja weit hinter den drei grünen
spitzenpolitikern hupac baerbock und
özdemir zurück ich
war ja lange ganz gut und irgendwann gab
es den relativ starken abschluss absturz
zugabe -16% ich habe das war im februar
und ist natürlich jeder wusste urlaub
chance ist er war vorher in hamburg auch
nicht anders als jetzt als bundeskanzler
ist und dadurch das eher zurückhaltend
ist haben natürlich die beiden grünen
wahnsinnig gute profilierung chance aber
es ist auch nicht ganz so dass alles an
allem schuld die letzten 16 jahre waren
wo die spd ja auch das ganze bei der mit
in der regierung war wir haben nämlich
das haben wir erfragt werden wohl schuld
daran ist dass wir diese abhängigkeit
von der energieversorgung von russland
haben und da sagt mehr als die hälfte 55
prozent sagen das sind beide parteien
schuld daran dass dass dies passiert ist
und es bringt ja auch nichts wenn man
jetzt rückwärts schaut und sagt
sind alle schuld dran und schauen was
wir mal anbieten wie der zufriedenheit
mit der bundesregierung ist die ist
nämlich gar nicht so gut und die ist für
die einzelnen parteien für die grünen
und die spd noch ein ganzes stück besser
also für die fdp war
ist da und wir sind ganzen abgestürzt
der spd ist bei der nähe ich will noch
eines sagen zur spd über die kompetenzen
an die spd hat ja jahrzehnte lang für
sogenannte soziale gerechtigkeit
gestanden und dieses wie kompetenz ist
runtergegangen zurückgegangen
zurückgegangen zurückgegangen und zwar
kontinuierlich seit vielen jahren früher
hatte sich noch darum gestritten ob sie
dann eher mit den linken ob die größere
soziale kompetenz haben die spielen auch
keine große rolle mehr und was passiert
mit den spd wählern sind gar nicht
wählen gegangen weil sie sich bei ihr
nicht mehr zu hause fühlten frau ramelow
ja ich möchte jetzt erstmal bevor ich
noch auf einige punkte eingehen so ein
bisschen der lanze für unsere
politikerinnen und politiker und auch
für olaf scholz brechen wenn ich
anschaue was für politisches personal in
anderen ländern zur auswahl steht dann
bin ich ehrlich gesagt froh dass wir in
der bundestagswahl meistens die auswahl
zwischen vielleicht auf den ersten blick
etwas ruhigeren vielleicht auch etwas
langweiligeren politikerinnen und
politikern haben aber das mal zur seite
gestellt wenn wir uns die letzte
bundestagswahl noch einmal genauer
anschauen und die beweggründe der
wählerinnen und wähler uns anschauen die
dazu geführt haben dass chance zu wählen
dann war es seine führungskompetenz die
wählerinnen und wähler haben ihnen
gewählt weil sie im führung zugetraut
haben und damit hat ja ja auch im
wahlkampf geworben wehrführung gestellt
bekommen sie fdp und grüne wurden
aufgrund von spezifischen themen gewählt
ob das finanzpolitische themen umwelt
energie und so weiter und das ist jetzt
eben auch das was olaf scholz zeigen
muss ich bin mir relativ sicher obwohl
ich jetzt in anführungsstrichen nur
beobachterinnen und nicht teilnahm
teilhaben de bin dass er nach innen
einigermaßen führt aber er muss es nach
außen zeigen und das fällt ihm glaube
ich noch ein bisschen schwer es ist
sicherlich auch so dass es einem
dreierbündnis anders ist als in einem
zweierbündnis und er schlägt sie hatten
es ja gerade auch vorhin gesagt er war
in der großen koalition mit angela
merkel da nahm sich keiner die butter
vom brot erbaulich viel butter auf dem
brot was kommunikation anbelangt aber
jetzt hat er eben zwei superstars neben
sich was kommunikation und darstellung
anbelangt und es lässt ihn noch mal ein
stück schwächer
kommunikativ aussehen als es diese zwei
super-stars das will ich
diese zwei superstars und daher
festhalten die turiner ihre arbeit gut
eigentlich machen die keine chance sie
tun die sache gut sie sind nicht einfach
stars dient das jetzt können und olaf
scholz kann es nicht und sie wenden sie
arbeiten gut und sie arbeiten natürlich
aufgrund der beiden ministerien und
öffentlich in der aktualität das gibt
ihnen diese präsent die der kanzler eben
anderswo holen muss er muss erklären was
er tut es ist eine neue situation wir
haben eine situation die man sich nicht
vorgestellt hat in den letzten jahren
seit dem kalten krieg man konnte sich
das nicht weil er dauernd ja da muss er
ja nein aber da muss ich das auch gute
marken
wenn man sich die spitzenpolitiker an
sie der koalition kommen habe und
baerbock einfach cool rüber als scholz
woran liegt das diese unterschiedliche
wahrnehmung auch dass gerade die beiden
grünen politiker die ja durchaus auch
schon ihre probleme hatten zb im
wahlkampf auch konkurrenten waren um den
kanzlerkandidaten job dass die plötzlich
so viel besser dastehen in der
öffentlichen wahrnehmung als der
bundeskanzler
ja wenn wir schon mal gesagt dass olaf
scholz vielleicht bei der bundestagswahl
führung als führungsstärke eingeschätzt
worden ist aber wer war denn sein gegner
das war armin laschet oder armin laschet
hatte tatsächlich bei der frage
führungsstärke
aber erkennbar große defizite und was
wir vorhin schon gesagt haben natürlich
sagt die bevölkerung sie ist klasse das
kabarett neue terminals 1 waren will
damit wir von dem erdgasleitungen
wegkommt sie findet es gut dass frau
berbalk klare partei ergreift und das
macht sie natürlich sehr populär und
werden sie nicht gerade bei den grünen
sondern werden dass spd politiker die in
der gleichen klarheit diese position
vertreten würden wären sie sicherlich
auch sehr populär aber die grünen haben
wie auch immer das große los gezogen
dass sie in anführungsstrichen natürlich
dass sie die beiden entscheidenden
ministerien haben die jetzt in
kriegszeiten besonders gefragt sind und
natürlich der worte lindner das
finanzministerium die ausgaben wie man
so auf sagt die spd kann ich mit dem
geld umgehen was natürlich nicht stimmt
aber um das zu kontrollieren und
ergebnis haben wir es ja nun alle
gesehen das sollten wir nicht so ein
bisschen die überzeugung mit habeck und
berbalk sein so ein bisschen
krisengewinnler sie waren im richtigen
moment am richtigen platz
außenministerium wirtschaftsministerium
dann kam der überfall auf die ukraine
frau meier und ist das etwas
wie ist diese ist dass damit alles
erklärt oder liegt es auch an noch
anderen dingen an persönlichen
vielleicht auch an inhaltlichen fragen
ich glaube es liegt auch tatsächlich an
der professionalität in den an der
kommunikation der ministerien aber es
liegt also wenn ich mir jetzt das
anschaue denke immer so oder scholz ist
quasi der bundestrainer oder sind seine
topspieler ja das ist so das team und er
hat ja auch leute und seinem team die
eigentlich unglaublich aufspielen
könnten zum beispiel die
bundesverteidigungsministerium die ja
nun gerade irgendwie ganz schlecht
performance fünf perform ja es geht um
sehr viel geld was du weisst die
steuerzahlerinnen steuerzahler gerade
raushauen für die bundeswehr und es sind
nur beiden pleiten pech und pannen da
gerade zu vermerken das finde ich ganz
schwierig und da muss sich die spd finde
ich auch strategisch in diesem fall zb
auch das vorsitzenden team und die
fraktionsführung mal fragen was können
wir hier ändern also dass ich finde
diesen ruf immer nach diesem er muss
erklären und wenn das erklärt er muss es
besser erklärt immer ein bisschen
schwierig sind ja alle keine kinder wir
können zeitungen lesen und wir können
uns auch unsere eigenen schlüsse mal
ziehen ja eigenverantwortlich es geht
nicht um großes theater aber was wir
gerade erleben ist quasi bei yamaha beck
das ist ja nicht nur das der irgendwie
keinen schlips trägt sondern der und er
sagt nicht nur der macht nicht nur gute
stimmung sondern er erklärt wie er die
probleme löst und wir sehen ihm dabei zu
und daran mangelt es einfach in bei der
spd ganz eng ist das der unterschied der
franca marge hervor hin so ein bisschen
auch schon angedeutet dass in dieser
krisenzeit die bündnisgrünen einfach das
überzeugendste auch inhaltliche konzept
haben also frieden nur bewaffnet
verteidigungs und sehr fähig und nicht
mehr ein naiver pazifismus und
und energie sollten auch die
gesellschaftliche transformation die ja
notwendig ist sind da die grünen einfach
überzeugender als die anderen auch
nachher richtig finde man sagen was man
schon spürt ist die mag sein dass die
grünen in den in der algen in den
allgemeinen zustimmungswerten gerade
mächtig zulegen aber ich glaube über die
mittlere und lange strecke kriegen die
ein echtes problem mit ihrer basis die
sind ja für was anderes gewählt worden
also da bin ich da wirklich jetzt keine
prognosen abgeben dann wissen
wahrscheinlich wissenschaftler innen und
lustiger mehr aber das glaube ich ist
auch eine konjunktur der wir gerade bei
bologna nicht über die grünen sondern
über zwei ringen die die wirklich stark
sind die uns auch sympathisch sind die
modelle sind davon reden wie man wenn
ich ihnen nur ein ganz kleines beispiel
von olaf scholz olaf scholz hat erklärt
warum er nicht nach schief geht er hat
eine gute erklärung er will nicht
einfach auch noch einfach dort seien
nicht der mann hat gesagt er will nicht
mehr so machen wahrscheinlich auch aber
er möchte etwas substanzielles machen
das typisch für die aber das muss er
bessere das musste sonst nimmt die
opposition auf das hat ja der märz
gemacht und uns sagen was heißt denn
dass er muss das erklären bei olaf
scholz ist viel substanz und wir haben
dieses substanz erfahren wird zu wenig
um das geht nicht darum dass wir da
rauskommen wird wesentlich nur zeitung
beschreiben sich sogar noch es geht
darum dass die ganz ich habe gesagt geht
denn morgens früh mit den kinder zur
schule geht dann muss das mitbekommen
denn muss das mitbekommen und das ist
eine andere klasse in diesem land nach
irland ist eine klassengesellschaft in
der die licht akademischen kreisen
völlig vernachlässigt werden gut ich
würde ganz gerne herr schlecker formelle
sie wollten beide noch eine anmerkung
machen wenn sie vielleicht kurz halten
können ich würde gerne daran andere es
noch niemand sprechen bitte verschlingt
bitte
ja gut weil er gerade über die grüne
basis gesprochen wurde und ich finde
schon interessant wenn man sich in
nordrhein westfalen über die wollten wir
ja auch mal wieder reden die
parteianhänger anschaut wenn es darum
geht früher den früheren kohleausstieg
zu machen dann kann man sich doch
wirklich ganz interessant sagen da sind
550 was man im runter gucken 88 der
grünen natürlich gegen dass der frühe ko
früheren kohleausstieg kommt aber auch
55 prozent der cdu wähler auch da ist
die mehrheit die sagt wir müssen aus der
kohle raus also so ganz glaube ich auch
nicht dass die grünen wähler
die realitäts bewusstsein abgeschaltet
haben ich denke eher dass wir wissen ja
auch dass viele grüne wähler dafür aus
eine sehr gute ausbildung haben auch zu
den besseren einkommensgruppen zählen
dass sie letztendlich akzeptieren und
sagen ist das tatsächlich eine
zeitenwende ist eine neue realität und
der müssen wir uns stellen ich glaube
nicht dass die probleme mit der grünen
basis sehr sehr groß werden sabine
ihr bild mit dem bundestrainer und den
den spielern also ihr fußball bild das
hat mir hat mir sehr gut gefallen ich
möchte noch eine sache zur zum
aussenministerium sagen und da noch was
zum politikstil von annalena baerbock
und robert habeck ich mein wenn ihnen
die geschichte der bundesrepublik
schauen dann haben aus hat das
außenministerium mit wenigen ausnahmen
die jetzt in der jüngsten vergangenheit
liegen also heiko maas und auch herr
westerwelle die nicht immer sehr gute
umfragewerte hatten aber ansonsten war
das außenministerium immer ein
ministerium beziehungsweise ein minister
der hohe umfragewerte genossen hat also
einfach mal so zur einordnung
ich glaube was uns was uns gut gefällt
oder was uns auch so anspricht an herrn
habe und frau werbung ist machen wir uns
doch nichts vor es sind auch neue
politiker und politikerinnen
wir hatten davor in den langen merkel
jahren jahr eine eine riege an
politikerinnen und politiker die wir
fast jahrzehntelang gesehen haben also
das neue macht bestimmt was aus der neue
politikstil dass man beiden letztendlich
auch beim denken zuschauen kann und dass
man auch durchaus fehler machen kann
will eine grünhelm ich glaube das ist
etwas was was ganz frisch ist und so
soll und muss olaf scholz nicht werden
das ist auch ganz klar ein bundeskanzler
kommuniziert anders aber da muss ja noch
seine rolle finden wenn die grünen frau
meier jetzt so einen guten lauf haben
haben sie dann auch in düsseldorf freie
hand legen sie sich zum
koalitionspartner nehmen
naja sagen wir mal andersrum die grünen
werden genommen also das noch nicht so
weit sind der oder die täter sei
unwahrscheinlich
aber ich finde sie haben natürlich
hatten sind sie in der absoluten macher
position jetzt und in der sich fast
verdreifacht der ergebnis wobei man wohl
auch noch die absoluten zahlen ist das
dann nicht mehr ganz so großartig aber
sie sind in der absolute machtposition
jetzt in düsseldorf
und ich habe heute mich noch mal
beschäftigt mit ein bisschen mit den
inhalten der wahlprogramme das passt
nicht so gut zusammen muss man jetzt
auch mal sagen also innere sicherheit
energie
kita das wird schon ein bisschen
kritisch denken kann man eigentlich
nicht unendlich viele ab verhandeln denn
der hier nur eine einzige möglichkeit
überhaupt
nicht über die fdp geht und das ist es
passiert uns einfach dazu möchte ich was
sagen die fdp also die liberalen bei uns
heißen die freisinnigen der schweiz
nicht die haben eigentlich den
schwierigsten stand historisch gesehen
in deutschland denn hamers schwieriger
nach schwieriger nein jetzt noch welche
massen in deutschland gab es nie einen
liberalen coach wie 18 48 am 12
september in der schweiz das war nämlich
endet die freisinnigen haben nachher 160
jahre fast regiert bestimmte dinge das
ganze das wesentliches dies gab es nicht
weil sie in der paulskirche dieses
scheitern gab und die die liberalen die
haben einen unglaublich schwierigen
stand die sind unglaublich volatil immer
wieder und das mir persönlich fällt eine
eine kraft eine liberale kraft und das
ist hoch bedauerlich natürlich haben sie
auch den fehler gemacht bei diesen
konjunktur kennen was jetzt gemacht
haben für die für die arbeitnehmer haben
sie hat die rentner nicht eingebaut das
sind alles schon fehler aber sie sind im
grunde genommen sehr sehr mutig und sie
sind in deutschland nötige als
vielleicht an dass die linke sie sind
wirklich nötig aber geschlagen also die
tragischen figur
ja genau ich meine genau ich meine wenn
sie von sich reden die die wirklich
etwas repräsentieren was ich meine
lindner ist eine tolle figur also
wirklich er hat auch unglaublich
substanz ich habe ihn gehört
philosophische vorträge das kam der das
sind tolle figur aber irgendwo steht das
mit den liberalen immer am verschlimmert
ich wollte noch mal sagen zu den grünen
wird die wird ja gerade so getan als
wenn das die sensation wäre wenn jetzt
hier weil in nordrhein westfalen
schwarz-grün käme ich dachte an hessen
erinnern er gibt schon ganz lange eine
schwarz-grüne koalition und da ist
jemand minister geworden der früher
gegen die startbahn west
protestiert hat und auch schleswig
holstein ich war auch da waren die
grünen in der landesregierung und haben
ja sehr erfolgreich da in einer jamaika
koalition das land geführt da sagt der
ministerpräsident das war so toll dass
für die grünen und die fdp darin hatten
lassen uns doch weitermachen mal sehen
ob es funktioniert also so was ganz
neues schwarz grün ist es auch nicht und
ich kann mir auch kaum vorstellen dass
in nordrhein-westfalen was anderes gibt
die fdp wird sich eher selbst auftreiben
wenn sie jetzt sagen würden beginnt mit
den grünen und der cdu
landesregierung kann ich mir nicht
verbrenne was glauben sie denn was olaf
scholz mehr stört das mit einer schwarz
grünen koalition in düsseldorf
gegenwind aus dem bundesrat kommt noch
mehr gegenwind oder dass da
möglicherweise ein konkurrenzmodell zur
ampel auf bundesebene ausprobiert wird
ja beides wird ihm nicht gefallen das
ist ganz klar
aber er wird gemeinsam mit seiner mit
mit seiner partei und auch gemeinsam mit
den koalitionspartnern in berlin
durchaus schlüssel jetzt aus diesen
beiden wahlergebnissen ziehen aus
schleswig holstein und aus
nordrhein-westfalen wobei ich die auch
schon noch mal so ein bisschen in den
kontext setzen möchten wir hatten
letztes war letztes jahr auch einige
landtagswahl die ähnlich wie schleswig
holstein auch abgelaufen sind das
einfach sehr beliebte amtsinhaber dann
den sieg nach hause fahren und in
nordrhein westfalen war es jetzt nicht
der vase nicht beliebter amtsinhaber
unter der schon lange beliebte
amtsinhaber aber ein amtsinhaber der gut
ins amt gekommen ist man muss das auch
so ein bisschen in das verhältnis setzen
es wird olaf scholz ist wird die
koalition beschäftigen aber es sind so
viele themen die die koalition gerade
bewältigen muss wir hatten es eingangs
der sendung gesagt die unterschiedlichen
transformation im digitalen bereich
energieinfrastruktur und das muss jetzt
alles in einem völlig neuen
koordinatensystem gedacht werden nämlich
indem koordinatensystem des krieges und
ich denke darauf wird er sich wenn die
politik im moment sehr in bewegung ist
frau maja ist die cdu wollen wir da noch
am zum schluss seinen aufträgen zurück
im spiel absolut also ich habe auch
gerade jetzt als ich hier den beiden
zugeschalteten gästen zugehört habe
weder schwarz-grün das war ja der traum
eigentlich also dann einem jahr hatten
der union und das war auch in absolut
greifbarer nähe also dann haben aber
beide ist schwere fehler gemacht der
armin laschet und annalena baerbock
schon allein mit der mit der ausrufung
von das heißt warum der vergleich der
innungs rufen vor ziemlich genau einem
jahr war das noch so armin laschet und
markus söder in den besteht deswegen
weil sie eine sekunde diesen jahres noch
ganz kurz vor ende war es aber was jetzt
jetzt sind wir an den punkt indem die
cdu vor tanzen kann was sie in drei
jahren dann im bund anbieten kann und
zwar in dem bevölkerungsreichsten
bundesland und ich glaube diese chance
wird sie sich nicht entgehen dass ich
denke die werden das richtig gut machen
und mit support aus berlin und machen
sie es dann richtig wenn sie friedrich
merz als übergangsvorsitzender
betrachten es gar nicht ob das nicht
vorsitzender ist das ist ja neu er war
ja nicht verdorben durch die 16 merkel
jahre den mann war früher und ist jetzt
und da ist das neue das sind neue
ist ein ganz großer nicht mehr
konkurrenzfähigen hinein aber dieses
millionen position was deutschland im
moment habe ist auch eine starke
opposition und das ist doch toll all das
habe ich doch vermisst es ist wirklich
eine starke opposition und sie gefährdet
die regierung sieht beeinflusst sie ist
doch toll die demokratie
funktioniert wieder schlingert ja und da
wird noch was sagen zu zahlen was
wunderbaren natürlich ist bei schwarz
grün die cdu hat es ja geschafft wieder
die wähler ab 60 jahren plus hinter sich
zu holen das war bei laschet anders und
sie sind bei den jüngeren schwächer aber
dafür sind die grünen bei den jungen
stark und bei den älteren schwächer
gehen sie zusammen haben sie die jungen
und herren sie die alten kann man sich
kaum besser vorstellen frau müller ist
sogar gerade schon angesprochen schwarz
grün das ist zwar eine option aber da wo
es inhaltlich müssen
ganze gruiten herten geschluckt werden
von beiden ist das jetzt auf die lange
projektion gesehen tatsächlich eine
option vor der sich dann olaf scholz
leben fürchten muss
also jetzt gucken erst habe ich in
nordrhein westfalen zustande kommt ich
gehe aber auch davon aus was anderes
kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen dass
es schwarz grün werden wird es wird da
noch wirklich davon abhängen wir haben
es ja gerade gehört friedrich merz ist
er der übergangs- vorsitzender oder
oder eben auch länger im rennen also
wird er vielleicht der nächste
kanzlerkandidat der union werden ich
denke dass mit den beiden jungen cdu
ministerpräsidenten die sich jetzt durch
die wahl in nordrhein westfalen und auch
durch die wiederwahl in schleswig
holstein jetzt letztendlich auch für
höhere posten in position bringen dass
davon auch viel abhängt ich könnte mir
durchaus vorstellen dass dann vielleicht
mit einem kanzler kandidat günther es
durchaus auch eine option schwarz-grün
im bund wer aber warum reden wir über
schwarz-grün im bund es könnte ja auch
grün-schwarz sein also ich denke in
dreieinhalb jahren kann wirklich noch
sehr viel passieren da werden wir also
in vielen phoenix sollten
das kommt jetzt auch noch dazu frau
meier vielleicht zum schluss wenn an
weihnachten in einer familie nur ein
teil der familie geschenkt bekommt da
gibt es oft übertragen jetzt auf die
ampelkoalition und wie man aus dieser
wahl in nrw ausgegangen es werden die
ich die jetzt eher zusammenraufen die
drei oder sich gegenseitig vermögen naja
ich glaube irgendwas dazwischen aber es
geht eher richtung vermöbelt aus meiner
perspektive also wenn wir uns gestern
die pressekonferenzen der der
parteivorsitzende angehört haben dann
ging es doch eher also die fdp ist jetzt
wild entschlossen sich neu zu
profilieren und gegebenenfalls auch
gegen innerhalb der koalition quasi als
kleine koalitions opposition da mache
ich mir ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen
sorgen weil wir brauchen natürlich auch
eine handlungsfähige regierung also das
wäre die opposition ist stark genug
gerade also da gibt es genug gegenwind
haben sie vollkommen recht ist auch gut
so aber die sollten schon gut
zusammenarbeiten aber ein bisschen
sorgen dass jetzt ein scheinbar sind wir
am ende der sendung herr muffin das
blieb das letzte wort zu haben ist der
koalitionsfrieden in gefahr wegen der
wahl in nrw die werden sich
zusammenreißen weil wenn sie das wenn
das auseinanderfällt kriegt jeder
negatives ab das glaube ich
wir durch und es ist auch die situation
nicht so dass man das einfach so kann
man muss da durch jetzt durch die
probleme die in denen die welt steht da
und deutschland ist eine sache es mal so
es fällt einem schweizer sehr schwer den
begriff zu brauchen eine weltmacht
wirtschaftlich kann man sagen die vierte
und das ist auch eine verantwortung und
nicht nordrhein westfalen sondern was
ist deutschland in europa in der nato in
diese welt wie beeinflusste deutschland
die den gang der dinge es ist ein
geschichtlicher moment und da wird das
war total verantwortungslos irgendwie
aus parteipolitischen gründen diese
ampel koalition zu springen ja das ist
das schlusswort gewesen ich bedanke mich
bei anja maier bei frank meyer bei
andrea römmele und bei reinhard
schlinkert die beide zugeschaltet waren
liebe zuschauer morgen in der phoenix
runde warten im stau warten am gleis
wann kommt die verkehrswende dann mit
anke plättner jetzt folgt phoenix der
tag mit mayer weber im rückblick in
einem nach einem notwendigen rückblick
auf die landtagswahl in
nordrhein-westfalen und wir schauen auf
die nato nord erweiterung um schweden
und finnland bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]